you guys wanted more Gordon Ramsay and I
deliver with apparently the greatest
episode I don't know what that means why
is my face burning ah
I don't know what I was thinking looking
into it
anyway let's watch scale Phoenix suburb
it's also home to Amy's Baking Company
Baking Company I've actually heard about
this episode I never watched it so my
expectations very high Sammy and Amy
buzaglo she looks absolutely terrified
that I discovered I had a real true
passion and talent for anything having
to do with the culinary arts then why
are you on this show
you're a Kitchen Nightmares explain
yourself so in 2006 Sammy invested over
a million dollars into this restaurant
to make my dreams I can help him yeah we
are ready never open a restaurant that's
the only thing I've learned from Gordon
Ramsay nightmares and kitchens are
disgusting approximately two years ago
these reviewers and these
lies and say that they ate the food and
it was disgusting he's so called
customers decided to write my what all
right so she's immediately not taking
accountability this should be
interesting when Gordon appears they're
just haters
haters do you think people go to your
restaurants just to write bad reviews no
they have a bad time there's a lot of
things that are wrong with the food that
she just doesn't realize too garlicky
too buttery too sweet not cooked enough
too overdone that doesn't work for me
if anyone tell me that my wife's food is
not good I just tell them to leave the
restaurant I don't want them and don't
come back hell yeah level 600 simp over
here
okay yeah it's your first time and last
time don't come back madam not only do
they lash out and swear at customers I
will go tell them to [ __ ] if my husband
doesn't but they take it one step
further and retaliate against them I
hope he eats it and I just made it
really spicy for him
this is a this is a for a great start
she's making food that she hopes hurt
people she's a witch Once I
went like a nice little
girl and the next second she's like
Cruella Deville I'm stopping all the
food
no yeah just it's just registered wait
you're it says Baking Company but
they're selling pizzas
unfortunately the majority of the people
in Arizona think that if you come to our
restaurant that we're gonna yell at you
scream at you and throw you outside and
that is not who we are keep walking
[Laughter]
well
it doesn't seem like it so far but I'm
willing to be remain open and unbiased
for Amy here she seemed lovely
let's get the man in here a day before
it starts the day before
do you understand
it will don't worry
[Laughter]
take the money
he has really started yet this is an
everyday kind of thing for them
I can't believe this restaurant has bad
reviews it seems like everyone's having
a great time yeah really fun for
everyone else just sitting as well you
guys I'm
think that you can come in here and say
these things are you kidding me this is
ridiculous I've never seen anything like
this
okay pretty good so far nice very little
knowledge previous night's dinner
service
hey Chef how are you how are you doing
nice to see you first name is Sammy
Sammy I'm the owner yes wow look at that
come on it looks pretty yeah uh can I
meet this lady yes please yeah and me
yes sometimes you want to meet you he
wants to know who is the chef of who
that's all that's beautiful uh come
around my darling so nice to meet you
give him hugs this is how it starts uh
did you make it let's get Star Struck
incredible likewise
I am yeah hold on stop stop holy crap
you got lucky I'm the lucky one he is my
soulmate and we're in this business
together can we stand strong together
yeah you're equally insane
we have to because there's a lot of
online bullies and haters and bloggers
you are the bullies how do how do people
get so delusional I never understand
zero self-reflection insane we stand up
to them and I think we're the only ones
that ever have as restaurant owners and
they come and they try to attack us and
say horrible things that are not true
because they're they're used to eating
processed wood chips or used to getting
things for free you can't get a word
um let's catch up with the haters
have a quick look at the kitchen of
course uh normally owners don't like it
when I expect kitchens but the floor's
shiny it's like a basketball court nice
I appreciate that you want the jacket
you don't need it it's like a doctor's
surgery in here yes it should be thank
you for saying the truth oh my goodness
me is this a joke I mean look dates
labels everything sectioned off wow what
a pleasure yeah that's great so it
should be God damn we can't find
Qualified people to work they want to
come and not work Arizona
this is really know that I think he's
worried is my biggest problem I'm pretty
sure anyone would be better than YouTube
there's
I think the place would
actually if you just stay out of it
dirty they're lazy how many have we been
for a few hundred loves a few hundreds
yeah so 100 no that's not possible get
out of here what's wrong with this
bloody restaurant I have issues with
customers that are trying to be online
bullies and say horrible things online
bullies this guy came in that started
this entire online bullying he ordered
pizza margarita and after I say okay how
is your pizza I say
a frozen pizza the next day he went and
gave us a review oh my God my wife she
was retaliated you wrote back to him oh
right why I told him I thought he was a
loser he was a [ __ ]
I understand he insulted me are you a
control freak I am yes
what a combination yeah
clone us
[Laughter]
well we have three little boys but
they're trapped inside cat bodies
thank you
the meow as well I really appreciate
that
they're my whole life besides my husband
and my business I speak feline
stop oh my God for the first time oh you
are both
[ __ ] nuts yeah it's pretty much just
me a month and a half good tips I don't
make tips say that again I make hourly
serious
to the only server in this country I
know that doesn't get tipped out so
where do the tips go the owner
that's so weird yeah you spoke earlier
about the problem with staff yeah I just
found out something pretty major Miranda
the young girl yeah you go give her her
tips no
Sammy cannot take service tips then
bring me the people who's going to do
their job and I don't have to interfere
they can take the whole tips for them
it's like we can't find proper staff
while we also screw them over completely
wow I don't understand how this happened
this story was becoming a little clearer
[Music]
okay yeah this is the chef's order okay
I believe that once Chef Ramsay tastes
my food as a chef he'll be able to tell
that this is what God wants me to do
what dough is raw dude I feel it it's
raw
story
I don't know how we come out today like
this but normally today yesterday
could play about the same thing what's
wrong nothing nothing
Sammy sugar coats a lot of what happens
in the restaurant so Amy gets this
feeling that like everything she's doing
is correct everything why am I so scared
of her with the knives I don't know why
she hasn't done anything violent but I'm
still terrified anytime I see her with
the knife I know my wife she doesn't
take the criticism she will be shaking
and then she said that's it I'm living
telling you the truth do you want to
tell her come with me you tell her he is
scared you tell her hey you want to come
with me
it's good that you can communicate with
your wife you know she will know I will
just go go out to another country and
I'll write her letter and then she knows
75 minutes in and so far I've had a
undercooked Pizza this is the reason I
never like going to restaurants in UK
because it'll always take like an hour
and I'm like what's the point you
wasting my goddamn time I wouldn't say
like all Japanese food are like the best
ever but at least you always get it at a
reasonable time and I think that matters
to me so much more is that just me I
ain't got an hour just to sit and have
lunch nah I'm a busy man and I get
hungry and a little cranky give me the
food now and then I gotta wait for them
to give me the bill what's up with that
a lot of nerve calling this a blue
ribbon Burger well I don't even know
what that is but yes that looks terrible
you're right it's not
ew oh
it's a greasy ass burger God damn I'm
Ewing because I've definitely had a
burger like that I feel like you're here
as well you know what I mean
hell
it'll stop squeezing it
is over complicated so unnecessary and
look
oh my God there's one there we go
don't worry Gordon Ramsay I I will tell
her I
I will just join Elon Musk at Mars and I
send Telegram
she will know she will know burgundy
could eat me eat me
[Music]
it has to be one of the most look at all
that corn in there disgusting I hate
corn corn the worst smash like if you
agree and smash like if you disagree
corn sucks only popcorn alarm corn
flavor okay but corn to consistency
sucks you know it does you buy it into
something so good what is this corn damn
it I hate it stupid corn ruined my life
we need to unite leave a comment
explaining why you hate corn and you
could win a live time supply of corn
look at this thing yeah
this is what I've been waiting for I
don't as an epic pescetarian I wouldn't
even want a salmon burger that sounds
gross
at least it doesn't drip okay it's like
a soup
I mean it's it's not good that was a lot
longer than I expected and you know
there were some big bumps in that meal
um what kind of bugs what didn't you
like let's go through it later okay okay
I'm gonna go get changed he's also he's
also gonna please
I'll tell you later
everyone's terrified of this woman and
her giant knives you look disappointed I
am disappointed okay but brought your
own Kitchen Nightmares what the f were
you expecting him to go this is amazing
I love everything wow you're the best
business ever I can't believe it
everywhere this is wrong I genuinely
feel like she would believe that she'd
be like yes
thank you these online haters and
Bullies
oh thank you yes thank you
yeah right in front of them let's Okay
go yes that's so good
I gave her the tip right in front of
them
now we get to see the pressure of
everything falling down why is watching
other people in pain so pleasurable I
don't know make me feel like I'm not
such a piece of after world I love it
hooray for reality TV so why can't you
go and tell your wife of course
[ __ ] wake up is undercooked I don't
think your pizza was undercooked I
checked it when I took it out of the
oven just like I do every other pizza
and to me it was crispy on the bottom no
more than Gordon so to me it wasn't okay
so that's your version because you
didn't see her come back however the bun
for the beef burger was soggy as
anything blue cheese marinated mushrooms
crispy bacon bits white truffle oil who
comes up with those ideas I did because
there's certain things that don't go
together and that's for them I have
never had a problem with that hamburger
ever
because your husband doesn't tell you
yeah exactly
oh gee I wonder why and I was having a
problem with it
about the 500 Burgers everyone hated why
like can't they just take criticism and
be like oh
you're right how should I make the pizza
better Gordon that's all you have to do
not just go there's something wrong is
it so [ __ ] hard God damn these are
store-bought crap frozen ravioli crap
and they're delicious and I the first
time I've ever cooked did you taste it
you didn't taste that one as a
strawberry ravioli can be really good
obviously but my monsters made it from
scratch many times it doesn't take
anything to take her that long I think
and it's so much better it's delicious
never had a problem with it but you
usually love it yes real customers not
haters oh come on Amy gravioli is better
you're just a hater door day God
sacrilegious ladies and gentlemen two
seconds please the owner is trying to
pull the wall over your eyes by offering
you frozen raviolis that aren't even
made within 500 miles of this front door
are you going to tell your wife or shall
I I will tell her thank you
[Music]
there's no way no more raviolis and no
more hamburgers and no more salmon
burgers people can only have kicks
tonight okay okay I'm good with that she
took that well
she can't take criticism why is that
yeah ask her that question ask her I
have the same problem for that
4B no no five beats are you sure you
don't need to question me Katie you can
go home right now I'm sorry Sammy I
would appreciate it if you would send
Katie home right now I don't need an
attitude from her she comes in her it's
because there's the two others oh my God
am I sure
what a little [ __ ] every single time a
customer doesn't lick their plate the
waitress doesn't come to tell me that
Amy no one's licking that that's
disgusting ignore him I am ignoring
everything that's happening stop thank
you excuse me
so
that just comes back to the table and it
goes straight into the pot wash then
they didn't like it so if they didn't
like it what are we going to do about it
let's wait we finished today the kitchen
needs to know okay then I'm going to
tell her thank you this guy is going to
tell it just soon very soon
they did like it there's no point in me
speaking so I'm just gonna work
it's like one long nightmare Kitchen
Nightmare
that's the name of the show do you think
the girls deserve some tips tonight no
take it hourly and so do you think if I
win and ask every customer when they
leave a tip that I go straight to the
owner and not to the server oh yes
please tell them let me ask that table
there so the tip that you left the young
lady server the owner takes the tips
got around me you asked him to be honest
answer my question answer my questions
tell the customers they're gonna get
their tips no they don't they should be
told that you're taking them because
this service deserve them you want with
me
threatening him what is happening this
is the weirdest [ __ ] episode
the kitchen yeah I feel like they'd be
better off running some kind of like
underground illegal business
genuinely and maybe kick some etymology
seriously what the [ __ ] they're so scary
and weird
listen to me when I'm speaking to you do
not walk away from me you don't work
here anymore okay
you just because he just fired her
[Music]
she comes to the kitchen tonight she's
like I said a table she said are you
sure
she's a poisonous little Viper and I
don't allow people to have an attitude
in my restaurant what does she know who
the hell is she she is gone that's who
she is don't let the door hit you on the
way out how do people
don't get it believe it or not my
intentions are good
I'm listening
it's become evident that you can't take
why is that are you seriously asking me
yeah yes you don't have to cry here I
don't want you to cry you don't have to
cry I'm not going to cry I'm trying to
speak and take out my
mind that's great you don't have to cry
don't cry
okay foreign
okay
you as well Sally Chef Ramsay has
arrived with a plan to start turning
around Amy's Baking Company
oh what but with Amy and Sammy not at
the restaurant
he takes the time to meet with former
staff members that have reached out to
him do they have a support group Henry
nice to see you uh first of all
Sammy told me that he didn't like people
who went to culinary school because he
didn't think that we knew anything and
when I started I was only allowed to
pour water glasses and set them at the
table so I worked out front for a few
months and basically had to beg my way
back into the kitchen
I'm Henry he was always in a bad mood no
matter what he made me wash his car one
day what that was the most ridiculous
thing I've ever done for him they were
always yelling at each other
it's just that they don't really know
how to manage a restaurant I don't know
what it is but they both think that like
the whole world is out together
who would have thought people with no
experience to run a restaurant doesn't
know how to run a restaurant I can't
believe it uh wish me good luck I need
it good luck absolutely good luck
because it plays closed wow it gets
worse holy good morning morning
today is a new day you said the salmon
burger was dry but it was wet is it dry
or is it wet which one is it one at a
time no you you're confused I'm not
confused when we're talking about food
but the way you screams are that young
girl last night would you let anybody
come into your restaurant in your
kitchen and speak to you the way that
that kid spoke to me me last night would
you she's like are you sure
for me are you sure you don't need to
question me Katie you can go home right
now that was it to fire her God damn I
was exaggerating again all right but you
claim her you blame the customers but
customers were waiting for the food
through your husband's mistake I met
Jessica and Henry this morning and I got
told some awful things like what the way
the haters they're bullies they have to
clean cars in the middle of service
because the boss wants his car cleaned
over 50 staff being fired in that short
period of time really 50 staff 50 staff
you're saying that I have fired 50 staff
since just you're saying that I am can
you prove that to me well you said prior
that you've hired hundreds staff so I
don't I think firing 50s it's not that
unreasonable claim
she was wrong 100 or even more than
100.50 yeah
she told me yeah
I need a drink of water excuse me
or drink and I have to drink water Jesus
Christ are you gonna attack me for
wanting to drink some water to my God I
don't even know why we came back here
I'm going home
[Music]
I'm just gonna drink water ah you're
gonna attack me for drinking water ah
I'm just gonna Breathe In and Out are
you gonna attack me for that as well I'm
just gonna leave I've had enough and
come here to be abused she really speaks
to herself a lot that's concerning
oh we've done all this happened is we
have been attacked
attacked why are you behaving because
I'm insulted you verbally insulted me
yesterday and I held my tongue out of
class I didn't tell you that that was
that was class yesterday
all right can I show you reviews
hundreds of reviews that are excellent
right there no good reviews real
customers that have supported us
you're attacking my business and my life
this is all I do is live this life every
day you're not telling me the problems
you are saying I'm delusional I'm in
this I'm this I'm this
can we talk about what we came here to
speak about please
not the problems that you've had that
you cannot talk to your wife and the
issues that she can't take criticism
I have a feeling this is going to go go
down here real fast but you're too far
gone okay then let's end the show you
think I'm too far gone there's no hope
yala it's Christmas let's go home it's
Christmas let's go home what is that
I can't help people
they can't help themselves
and it's not normal for a restaurant to
go through that many staff it's not
normal for a kitchen that small to have
65 items on the menu and it's not normal
for the level of animosity that you've
built inside this restaurant and outside
you have the right to run the business
the way you want to run your business I
have the right to do the right thing and
the right thing for me
oh okay I got that one wrong mistread
the tone I guess
wow yeah of course that's what I wanted
to participate in this [ __ ] yes I
can't wait to look up this restaurant we
don't need his help maybe he knows that
it all has to come down
and now he's gone he walked away he'll
go on with his life Sammy and I will go
on with our life it's finally happened
after almost 100 Kitchen Nightmares I
can two owners who I could not help and
it wasn't because I didn't want to it
was because they are incapable of
listening they need therapy kitchen
therapy Amy's Baking Company
yeah
they held on dude 2015. well
that's all right I kind of want to go
there for the experience you know just
go there and say the say the
say the pizza though is soggy and just
see what happens
oh so the problem according to them
which the former landlord not the TV
show not at all wait there's still
[ __ ] articles coming out about this
okay so after eight years she says she's
grown and she regrets she regrets her
behavior in the show whoa what
looks like she's just making cakes now
good for her that's clearly what she was
good at I don't need to know who makes
my cakes great [ __ ] episode
thoroughly enjoyed great recommendation
if you guys have any other so you want
me to check out let me know in the
comments let me know how much you hate
corn I know because I just want to know
I'll see you guys in the next one
hey guess today's sponsor
wrong North VPN all right cyber security
at trivia time another chance I'm giving
you one more chance let's say you click
on a dodgy website you end up clicking
on a bad link your cool computer is
compromised they have everything
everything what do you do foreign wrong
this shouldn't even happen because you
should have nordvpn at all times idiot
okay one more you connect to a public
Wi-Fi network
what do you wrong use nordvpn every time
you connect to public Wi-Fi network
otherwise you're done okay one more if
you want to watch shows in other
countries what all right
install we know VPN you get access to
almost every country in the world the
internet is free hurray as it should be
thank you nordvpn kiss you but I can't
kiss you you're a computer program for
those of you who miraculously got all
the questions right I know you're
incredibly intelligent but here's the
twitch that's your grandma have nordvpn
check her computer right now I'll wait
here
that was fast impressive cyber security
thanks do you know who's most vulnerable
old people help out your old people in
1998 my grandma gave me the greatest
gift of all Zelda Ocarina of Time for
Christmas I'm paying it back I'm giving
my grandma a nordvpn subscription as
always you get a huge discount on a
two-year plane
everyone should have this even your
grandma sign up using the link in the
description that's nordvpn.com PewDiePie
that's how you get access to the offer
click the goddamn link use the link
you're welcome say thanks all right
bring your grandma and tell her tell her
to tell me thanks
I'll wait okay that was fast thank you
no vbn for sponsoring this video